[Applause]
watch out world
Capri Bryant is on the move on Sunday
proud mama Vanessa Bryant shared a video
to Instagram of her and her late husband
Kobe Bryant's youngest daughter taking
her first steps
Vanessa captioned the cuties milestone
well my baby so proud of my cocoa bean
Capri took her first step from her unti
soul feed some mama today capris first
steps come just before her first
birthday on June 20th and this special
moment for the family comes four months
after Kobe and 13 year old Gianna were
killed in a helicopter crash after their
tragic loss the family has been trying
to make the best of things recently
Vanessa celebrated her first Mother's
Day without her husband and Gigi she
used the holiday as a moment to share a
special message to her daughters in a
heartwarming Instagram post the mama for
shared this photo a collage that her
oldest Natalia created for her she
captioned the picture quote I love being
your mama at Natalia Bryant Gianna
Bianca and Capri hashtag my world you
are all the very best of mommy and daddy
speaking of the very best of mommy and
daddy earlier this month
Vanessa shared this picture of Capri and
captioned it quote Capri looks just like
her daddy she also may note that in the
pic the baby girl is rocking one of her
big sister Gigi's old outfits on May 1st
Vanessa shared a heartfelt message to
Gianna on what would have been her 14th
birthday
Vanessa shared this photo captioning a
quote mommy loves you more than I can
ever show you you are part of my soul
forever I miss you so much every day I
wish I could wake up and have you here
with me I miss your smile your hugs and
your giggles I miss everything about you
Gigi I love you so much when it comes to
how the Nessa is managing it all here's
what her good friend Lala Anthony told
et I tell her every day she's the
strongest woman I know and I'm really
really proud of just how she's handling
everything and just want to continue to
be there you know as much as I can for
her as a friend she's just an amazing
and amazing human being
[Music]